محادثه نوويه في طهران الى ماذا تحدث هل
هي لتحريك جهود مفاوضات العوده للاتفاق
النووي ام هي لزياده عمليات التفتيش قبل
بلوغ طيران عتبه القنبله النوويه هنا يجيب
المدير العام للوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه بدعوه ايران الى الشفافيه بشان
برنامجها النووي وفي زيارته اليها كان امن
مستقبليه رفع العقوبات الدوليه القاسيه
ولو جزئيا لانعاش الاقتصاد المنحك وكبح
السقوط الحر للعمله المسحوق بالتضخم اما
في الشارع فالبعض ارجع انهيار الاقتصاد
للعقوبات الامريكيه فيما يرى اخرون ان ذلك
يعود الى سوء الاداره وان اختلف
الايرانيون حول اسباب التدهور الاقتصادي
فان سوء الحال يجمعهم اذا السقوط حر
للعمله الوطنيه في ايران حجج جاهزه يقدمها
النظام وغضب شعبي تصاعد خاصه من اولئك
الذين يكافحون لتامين قوتهم اليومي نصف
سكان ايران يعيشون تحت خط الفقر وبحسب
موقع مودرنسي الاسباب تعود الى ارتفاع
الاسعار وتراجع القيمه الشرائيه للعمله
المحليه غضب اجبر المرشد علي خميمائي على
الاعتراف بوجود ثغرات اقتصاديه عديده خامن
تحدث عن ثنائيه التضخم وانخفاض قيمه
العمله الوطنيه نسبه ارتفاع الاسعار بلغت
في بعض المدن
53% والحديث هنا لمصادر مح
[موسيقى]
ليه